pues como bien dices es un primer
borrador que abarca todos los documentos
que se están discutiendo en esta cop 26
incluidos acerca del acuerdo de parís en
el hacen mención a la ciencia a la
importancia de basarse en la ciencia
para las acciones y para la toma de
decisiones políticas también reconocen
que la adaptación va a incrementar las
necesidades de adaptarse al cambio
climático van a ir incrementando a
medida que aumenta esa temperatura
planetaria y enfatiza la preocupante
falta de fondos para los países
desarrollados para que precisamente se
puedan adaptar a este clima cambiante
también reconoce la importancia del
papel de la sociedad civil de los
indígenas de las mujeres en la acción
climática y en la acción
en el activismo climático y pide o dice
advierte que las decisiones que están
puestas en esta declaración dependerá de
la disponibilidad de recursos
financieros también incluye por primera
vez y con respecto a un texto al que
tuvimos acceso el lunes la mención a la
necesidad de ir dejando de lado el
carbón como método de energía y también
las subvenciones a este material pero es
el único combustible fósil al que se
hace mención esto puede ser reflejo de
la alta participación del lobby de
combustibles fósiles que hay que
mencionar que si fuera un país tendría
la delegación más alta en esta cop 26
con más de 500 representantes además hay
que ver si está inclusión del carbón en
este documento aguanta hasta el texto
final estuve hablando con algunos
representantes de ongs de sociedad civil
y la primera palabra que me dijeron en
cuanto a reacciones a este texto es
decepción decepción porque los derechos
humanos no están incluidos realmente en
este texto y cuando sí lo están están
incluidos entre corchetes es decir que
es muy probable muy probable que no se
vayan a llevar a cabo y para finalizar
básicamente es un resumen de todos los
temas de los que hemos estado hablando
durante toda la cobertura de esta cop 26
aunque todavía hay tres días de
negociaciones incluido hoy hasta el
viernes a las seis de la tarde ahora en
la que tendrán como fecha límite para
entregar el texto final un texto por el
que llevamos esperando dos años